Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie, Winter is coming
It looks like House of the Dragon Season
2 will be bringing back
the white Walkers in the night King
Based on a recent teaser
and some new footage
of what's going on up in the north
and what's going on
with house stark and the wall.
I know there are a lot of questions
about what
the white walkers
were doing around this period in history
hundreds of years
before the events on the main show.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll be doing bonus videos
until we get to season two.
they're supposed to be
releasing it around this time next year,
like around the time that season
one came out.
That part of the year
during the last few months,
one of the biggest new locations,
House of the Dragon, has been filming.
Season two episodes was up in the north
and for all the house stark, the Cregan
stark storyline that they'll be
adapting from the Dance of the Dragons.
They also just cast Cregan Stark too, so
let's talk about him later in the video.
unlike Jon Snow,
he will know a few things.
but expect a lot more Easter eggs
for stuff that'll be happening
later in the timeline
during the time of Jon Snow and dangerous
whole idea though, is the
Cregan Stark was a huge ally of Raniere
as during the dance and helps them a lot
through the rest
of what will be the series.
Like all the rest of the seasons
they tease that at the end of season one,
Jacare has agreed to fly
his Dragon VMAX to Winterfell
to try and win him to their cause.
I've already done
a ton of videos about Cregan Stark
and what's happening with him
during this part of the timeline,
like what's happening
with how stark just in general.
So I'll link those at the end of this
and down to the description below.
during the big time
jump in House of the Dragon.
Cregan Stark
kind of went through his own version
of what Rhaenyra is going through
right now up in the north.
so he's very sympathetic
to what is happening to Rhaenyra
right now in present day.
but when they just started
filming these episodes,
you can see all the house Starks soldiers,
the other men marching through the snow,
all the snowy
wooded areas around the north.
And you look at this footage
and it seems like they would also
be visiting the wall in the night's
watch at some point during the season.
this would actually be the first time
we've seen the wall
since the main show, Game of Thrones,
because they changed the intro.
They used to reference the wall
and all the Game of Thrones intros.
the new opening
scene is meant to be the valerian free
hold showing the Targaryen bloodline.
sort of like a really cool
3D family history.
I've already done many videos
breaking down all the different Easter
eggs in the way
they changed the House of the Dragon intro
to each episode during my episode videos
for season one,
So you can watch those again
if you want to learn
how they changed the intro
for each episode.
basically any time anybody dies
or anybody is born, they change the intro.
but at this point in the timeline
on House of the Dragon, much closer
to the time of Aegon
the Conqueror, even though he died way
before the events of the show,
the night's watch is way more powerful,
even though the many castles
and the forts that existed along
the wall have fallen into disrepair
and not all of them are manned
regularly anymore.
right now.
At this point in history,
there's this way more attention
on bolstering
the forces of the nights. Watch.
so it was much bigger at this point
than it was about 200 years later
when the events of the main show pick up,
we mostly have Aegon the Conqueror
to thank for that with his Dragon dream.
But the long night, the White Walkers,
the Night's King, His prophecy
of a Song of Ice
and Fire in around the time
they were filming
these scenes up in the north,
someone released a picture of them
putting together undead characters.
So zoom enhance that would be for wights.
So it seems like House of the Dragon
will be referencing actual wights, white
walkers, the Nike just in general.
At some point during season two,
there were so many Easter eggs
for the long night.
During season one, it makes sense
that they would just do more stuff
for that in season two next big question
everybody has is, yes,
the White Walkers were still active
after the first long night.
Even at this point in history.
It's just that they weren't as active
until much closer to the time
leading up to the main show,
charting the timeline
a little bit in the books,
it's a little bit different.
The first long night
was about 8000 years ago on the show.
They changed that and just said
it was more like a thousand years ago.
So for the purposes
of House of the Dragon,
you have to use the show's timeline
just because it's basing
everything
on the original Game of Thrones show.
What happened after the first long night
is that Bran Stark
ancestor called Bran The builder
was the king of winter at the time.
The king in the north, King in the north,
this is long before Aegon's conquest,
so there are many different kings
in different realms all over Westeros.
bran. The builder is not meant to be time
traveling.
Three-Eyed Raven Bran.
That was a theory for a long time,
but it's not true.
It's just one of his ancestors.
Bran wasn't named for him either.
He was named for his uncle, Brandon Stark,
Ned's older brother who was killed
by the mad King, along with his father,
Rickard Stark,
which started Robert's rebellion brain.
The builder worked
with the children in the forest,
the Giants, the other survivors
from the first long night
to build the wall in Enchanted
with the children of the forest Magic
preventing the night
king the white walkers
from crossing to the south.
the actual construction of the wall
took way longer than bran
the builders lifetime.
You have to remember,
this is like a thousand years ago.
It stretches 300 miles from east.
Watch by the sea
to the Shadow Tower on the West coast.
And they built 19 large castles
at equal intervals along
and manning them with 10,000 men at the
very beginning of the night's watch.
That's the most powerful that they ever
were The whole idea, though,
is that during the first long night,
they killed
the white walkers in the wights,
but not the Night King himself.
So he survives to slink off to the lands
of always winter and just go dormant
long enough to cause the brown to slowly
forget about him.
Slowly, he begins to turn into a legend,
and some people in the north
just begin to talk of him in tales.
Kind of like old man's tales.
not expecting to see spiders
big as hounds on House of the Dragon.
But that would be really cool.
what wound up happening is that over time
the different kings around
the realm would send
fewer and fewer men supplies
to replenish the forces along the wall,
because they didn't think
that there was that much threat
and over time, people started to forget
about the white walkers, the night king
and started to believe that the wall
was built to keep the free folk
out of the South.
So that's
where most of their attention lay
there were also other races,
other things in the north of the nights
Watch were trying to keep from coming
south.
Like the things, for example.
So over time, the nights
watch forces begin to dwindle.
They aren't able to maintain
all 19 castles
and some of them start falling apart
until you get closer to present day
during House of the Dragon in the manger,
where they only have enough men to man
three castles, Castle, Black
in the Middle East, watched by the sea.
And then on the West coast,
the Shadow Tower.
there was some evidence of white Walker
activity during that giant gap in history
between the building of the wall.
In present day,
the 13th Lord Commander of the nights
watch was called The Night King,
who said to have taken a white walker
led forces of wights
against his former nights
which brothers,
but then was defeated
with the help of the Wildlings at the time
that legend
is probably based on the 13th Lord
Commander being turned into a white walker
by the night King, who we know survived
and just became more active at that point
briefly in history in attempting
to break through the wall, unsuccessfully
after that, the night's
king would have got a little more dormant
until he developed his new plan
that he continued to use up to present day
forming pacts
with different people in the North
to sacrifice their male children to him
in exchange for immunity
from the white walkers. closer
to present day.
The night King was using crafters
male children for his forces.
That's why
many of the white walkers in present day
serving under him or actually Gilly's
Brothers.
There were lots of memes and jokes about
this when the main show was going on.
we never actually saw Gilly references
verbally, but she probably eventually
made the connection in the background
just because she was able to help
SAMWell discover
that John Snow was actually the child
of Lyanna Stark in regard to Morgan.
So she could probably figure out that most
of the white walkers were her brothers.
But before Craster lived the night.
King would have made pacts like this
with previous Northmen.
And over time,
I think the idea is that occasionally
white walkers would be killed.
He'd use new sacrifices
to replenish his forces
and just slowly building them
to present day on the main show.
When his army grew big enough to assault
the wall again, winds up happening
is that hundreds and hundreds of years
go by with the realm eventually
forgetting about the white walkers
focusing on the free folk until Aegon
the conquerors time about 115 years
before the events on House of the Dragon.
One night Aegon has his dragon dream about
the second long night in the night King.
The white Walkers later they call
the Prophecy a song of ice and Fire.
He edges the prophecy
onto his Valyrian dagger with the help
of the Bulgarian Pyromancer, as in passes
the blade in the knowledge
of the Dragon dream to his successors,
from King to successive King,
His whole reason for conquering
the Seven kingdoms was because he felt
like the realm would not be strong enough
to defeat them unless it was united in.
After he finishes conquering Westeros
and moves the capital to King's Landing,
he spends most of the rest of his life
traveling around to each of the six realms
because Dorne wasn't conquered yet.
They hated him still and there were still
minor skirmishes that he had to put out.
But he flew around on his dragon, bleary
in the black dread, also putting renewed
interest on the wall, boosting the night's
watch forces that focus on the wall.
The night's watch continue
through the time of King Jr is who is
Rhaenyra is great grandfather.
They don't reference the wall
the night's watch that much
during the events of season one
when her father Viserys was king.
But we learned that he was obsessed
with the prophecy.
So he would have also kept
a lot of importance
on maintaining the night's
watch during his reign.
It was just that he didn't tell anyone
until Rhaenyra
why he felt like the night's
watch was so important
Later in season one,
when Rhaenyra finally tells Daemon
about the white Walkers in the prophecy,
she references the fact
that part of the reason
for wanting to be queen
so badly is so that she can defend
the realm
against this threat of the night.
KING In the white walkers, George R.R.
Martin said that after Aegon's
Dragon Dream,
nobody actually knew
when the next long night would come.
So each king that came along
and learned of the prophecy would assume
that it could happen at any moment.
see that the picture of the series
sitting there at all times just thinking
the long night could happen at any moment.
And now Rhaenyra
is kind of doing the same thing.
So when?
Present day
during the dance of the Dragons.
It's not so much that Rhaenyra wants to be
queen purely out of selfishness.
She's also worried
about the white walkers.
And because the greens don't know about it
yet, Aegon
The second hasn't been told the prophecy.
She feels like the round will fall.
but because we know that it won't happen
until more than 200 years later.
And there were no major reports about huge
white walker battles between the dance.
The Dragons in present day.
it's likely
that if we see them during season two,
it'll only be a few of them
and it might be more like
the white walkers In the opening scene
from Game of Thrones Season one.
Like the show started
with the scene of the night's watch,
finding the dead
bodies made into ancient symbols,
referencing the Church of the Forest.
Then they were all killed
except for one of them.
We might get a scene
kind of like that The other major news
is that they finally cast Cregan Stark.
He's being played by Tom Taylor.
I've already done
a bunch of Cregan Stark video,
so I'll link those at the end of this down
to the description below.
once we get a picture of him
in actual costume, like in full makeup,
I'll do a first look video.
just assuming
that they will color his hair brown
because the seed is strong
to make more Jon Snow jokes.
a lot of people asked about this,
why Jon Snow doesn't have White Targaryen
customary hair.
it's because of the genetic trait
for brown
hair is more dominant than the trait
for white hair.
so for example, if Jon Snow
engineers were to have a child,
that child would also probably have brown
hair.
there's an awful lot of fan
art of that, too.
Like what it would look like
if they actually had children in.
Most of them have the white hair
which is technically incorrect.
It would be brown hair
once all the strike stuff in Hollywood
gets settled, George R.R.
Martin and HBO will start making
more announcements about season two,
the other Game of Thrones
prequels and spinoffs they're working on.
They're still almost seven, only one
or two of actually being canceled.
Most of them are still on stages
of different development.
the next big Game of Thrones series
that they confirmed they'll be releasing
will be the Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms one
Based on the Tales of Dunk and Egg
I've already done a teaser trailer video
for that.
Click here to watch that, learn
what's going on with that series
and click here to learn
what's going on with Cregan Stark
and how stark during the events of House
of the Dragon Season 2.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!